so sometimes it's hard to see the
outlines because we're right in the
middle of it but america really is in
the middle of a profound
social upheaval nothing is the same as
it was a year ago that's not your
imagination it's really happening
what we're seeing is an actual history
changing revolution in faith in place of
robespierre's famous
liberty equality fraternity our hr
departments have produced their own
three-word revolutionary slogan
diversity equity inclusion now this is
different
from what's happened in other countries
unlike the revolutions in most places
in america the working class is not the
hero of this story
our working class is the villain this is
not a proletarian revolution it's a
revolution from above it's aimed
straight downward
and you can tell by who's running it
college professors write the radical
literature
politicians put their words into
practice the biggest companies in the
world pay for all of it
so maybe not surprisingly for all their
revolutionary fervor the groups pushing
this revolution
leave their own power untouched when you
hear people talk about
dismantling systems of oppression
they're not talking about themselves
they're talking about you this is a
revolution expressly designed to empower
the already powerful and it's been that
way since the first day since this
summer when george floyd died in
minneapolis
now the first and most obvious question
we might have asked at the time
and no one ever asked this but it's
clear why was a 46 year old man reduced
to passing badly counterfeited 20
bills in a convenience store in the
middle of the day
george floyd was unemployed why was he
unemployed how many other people
like george floyd are unemployed and why
now that would have been an interesting
conversation it might have been a
fruitful conversation for all of us but
we didn't have it and we didn't have it
by design
instead we learned a lot about the
racial composition of the minneapolis
police department
we were told the police there weren't
quote diverse enough and that was a
national emergency
months later blm mobs destroyed the city
of kenosha wisconsin and once again we
were informed that the main problem
was a lack of diversity among kenosha's
low-paid cops
quote overall the local kenosha
newspaper announced with what sounded
like genuine alarm
the city's police force is 89 percent
white while the city's population is
about 67 percent white
okay kenosha too many white hourly
workers makes your city burn that's the
message
and as a result of that message
everything changed
but actually not everything changed in
fact many things stayed precisely the
same
patterns of residential segregation for
example they didn't change
they accelerated barack obama's
neighborhoods in washington hawaii and
martha's vineyard
are probably less quote diverse than
they were a year ago and that won't
change soon because too many people
who have a lot of money live there but
most striking of all now that we're
discussing things that haven't changed
at all have been the universities
the overwhelming majority of the ideas
behind this revolution
come from college campuses everything
you hear about white privilege and
systemic racism began as a lecture about
deconstruction in some classroom in the
1990s
and that's why so many blm activists
talk like sociology professors
but most of the actual changes on
college campuses have been superficial
yes the coursework is very different
yale no longer
even pretends to teach its students
anything it just indoctrinates them
but here's what hasn't changed at all
and this is the key to everything
what hasn't changed at all is the kind
of people who go to yale in the first
place
they're rich kids from rich families who
plan on staying
rich not speculation here are the
numbers before kovid the median family
income in the united states was about 65
grand a year
at yale it's three times that the median
family income of a yale university
student is 192
000 a year that's the median at the
university of pennsylvania it's about
196 000 a year at brown university in
providence
it's 204 thousand these are all ivy
league schools with
multi-billion dollar endowments
endowments heavily subsidized by you
through your tax dollars so they could
afford to educate poor kids
they just choose not to at princeton 72
percent of students come from families
in the top
20 nationally for household income
nobody seems to have
any plans to change any of this
diversity is for wage earners not for
the people in charge
no one's trying to diversify prestigious
campuses because in real life let's be
honest
the lack of diversity is the real reason
that people go there in the first place
no one applies to yale in order to learn
things that's not the point
the point of going to yale is to cement
your position as a credentialed member
of america's ruling class that's the
singular purpose of the experience the
only purpose
more than any other standard more than
any award
in american society an ivy league degree
increases the chance that those who hold
it
in the end will be giving the orders not
taking the orders
that effect is real and it lasts for
generations when you go to yale your
grandkids probably won't have to work
construction
so the question is why should this
arrangement continue and that's a
serious question especially now
if you're going to dismantle systemic
power and we've decided we are going to
you probably shouldn't start with
unionized cops in kenosha
you probably should start with systems
that wield actual power
america really does have a class system
they're absolutely right about that
that system is getting more rigid by the
day and we should probably do something
about it pretty soon
or the next revolution might not be as
peaceful as this one
so here's an idea beginning immediately
the top ranked 50 colleges and
universities in america should be
prohibited
by force of law if necessary from
accepting students whose parents or
grandparents went to college
no more rich kids harvard should be
reserved exclusively for students who've
never experienced
the many advantages of living in a
ruling class if you're for diversity
equity and inclusion
there is no faster way to achieve it
than this
so what would happen to harvard if we
did this wouldn't be hard for harvard or
any top school to find new students
millions of college-age kids are itching
for the opportunity and we know who they
are
for example the biden administration has
just announced plans to give amnesty and
citizenship to an estimated 30 million
foreign nationals now living in the
united states illegally
now as of right now you should know this
there is no plan to elevate
any of these new americans into our
middle class
no the plan is to keep them in serfdom
at the bottom of the economic ladder
someone needs to trim our trees and toss
our kale salads
that's the view of democratic donors and
they get their way always
but why should the rest of us accept
their plan
designed only to benefit them it's so
obviously unfair
why shouldn't the children of
impoverished illegal aliens go to duke
cornell stanford williams amherst
princeton
why shouldn't they occupy every single
bed on every single one of those
campuses
but wait a second you ask says the
democratic donor
if the honduran immigrants get into
colombia who's going to work at the
chicken plants
oh good question we nominate the
children of new york times editors
now new york times editors might not
like this arrangement very much
they may incite revolution at work but
at the same time they are fanatically
intent on sending their own kids to yale
and they will do absolutely anything to
get them into yale
they definitely don't want their kids
working at chicken plants they want them
working at mckinsey
but the problem is in a revolutionary
moment like this you can't always get
what you want
especially when you're as committed to
diversity equity and inclusion as your
average new york times editor claims to
be
in order to make omelets in this world
you've got to break some eggs
so here's our advice to the members of
the woke professional class at the times
and elsewhere
who are about to discover that their own
rules might actually apply to themselves
here's our advice stop complaining when
you discover that your own children's
life plans have been thwarted due to
some new imperative of social justice
don't say a word don't whine or moan or
file a lawsuit
don't even acknowledge it's happening
just accept it
it's not like you can pretend you didn't
know that meritocracy was fake
you single-handedly destroyed it
yourselves for years you thought you had
an exemption to the rules that you made
you imagined that challenging power
applied only to
other people's families sorry the
revolution has finally come for you
you pictured your kids graduating from
the local friends school
and moving on to cornell to immerse
themselves in gender studies and
international relations
oh but not anymore it's a new era again
an era that you designed
now your kids will be taking the bus to
a poultry processing facility in rural
iowa
to begin their new lives serving the
critical culinary needs
of the people they replace the ones now
going to cornell
and maybe someday if they're lucky your
kids can learn to code
but no matter what happens to them over
the next several generations don't fret
and once again above all
don't complain complaining is racist
diversity is our strength we're a nation
of immigrants
that's the main idea of america which is
you have often told us
is simply an idea not a nation now all
of this might be hard for you to see
right now it's painful and we get it
because it's happening to you it might
even seem unjust
trust us it's not unjust it's the
definition of justice